[Music]
good afternoon it used to be an
uncontroversial statement bad boys are
sexy from iconic actors like james dean
and johnny depp to fictional characters
like james bond and indiana jones the
silver screen served us up the men
your mothers probably warned you about
but now traditional masculine qualities
are being called out as toxic and many
people
want to cleanse the world of the men we
love to hate so should we celebrate the
opportunity to redefine masculinity
replacing bad boys with more positive
role models and if so what does the new
masculinity look like and does it still
have sex appeal or do we need to admit
that danger is integral to desire and to
see the attempt to cleanse masculinity
of all of its vices as a mistake that
will leave everyone worse off
well to help us answer
quite a lot of questions there we have a
stella panel
ella wieland is a political commentator
a journalist at spiked and she is the
author of what women want fun freedom
and an end to feminism
rohen pelling is a journalist and
broadcaster she's the former editor of
the erotic review and in 2017 rowan
launched the amerist a magazine with the
aim of countering the quote modern
tendency to see sex through a purely
functional prison
and miriam francois is an anglo-french
writer and broadcaster and she has
launched the website we need to talk
about
whiteness.com with a view to encouraging
conversations about whiteness and its
cultural impact
so if you've been to one of these
debates before you'll know that we'll
ask each of our speakers to begin with
an opening statement or a pitch
and the question we're going to ask them
to address is
is danger integral to
desire
uh ella why don't you start us off
thanks
um
i mean it's it's interesting that the
word fiction was used in the
introduction because i think that anyone
who's ever met a bad boy in real life
knows that actually the fictional nature
of that um stance usually falls away
it's very rare that you do meet a real
movie style bad boy usually they're
rather more pathetic once you get past
the facade
um but i think the more serious point in
relation to this there's two serious
points one is that i think
we use toxic masculinity today as a
byword for masculinity and i think that
um putting aside the very obvious points
that there's a very real uh need and a
great moral stance in condemning bad
behavior whoever does it bad boy or
otherwise um i think what's happened is
that we've problematised
perhaps the good things of masculinity
rather than taking them away and saying
these things are are positive outlooks
whether that be kind of stoicism
strength risk taking and say that
doesn't need to be masculine but hey
let's let's look at it as a good
uh form to
base yourself around um instead we've
trashed the whole idea so i think we've
interchangeably using toxic masculinity
and masculinity and i think that's a
problem because i think that we
shouldn't be throwing the baby out with
the bar four in that respect and the
second point is that i think the desire
to politicize people's very personal
things like sexual desire um is really
lesser comment on men
and in this instance more of a comment
on women and i think that what we say
and when we really what we're saying
when we're saying it's dangerous for us
to promote the sexual desire or
sexuality around the figure of bad boys
is that that's an inherent threat to
women and that women can't really handle
uh tussling with a bad guy and that i
think is a far more dangerous
prospect for women's freedom than any
james dean type figure
thank you very much ella
miriam is danger integral to desire
well according to one of my uh favorite
um
very and now famous sex therapist
esther's perel it absolutely is
you can't desire what you already
possess is what esther perel tells us
and so i do think there's an element to
the conversation around bad boys which
is the idea of something that you can't
quite
fully grasp and that is a
definite fuel for desire in both
directions i personally prefer bad girls
and bad women to bad boys but um
and i i think it's quite important to
make a statement about who we think
about when we think about bad girls and
bad women i mean i don't think they're
quite equivalent in when we talk about
the characteristics that we think of
when we talk about a bad boy what do we
mean versus what we talk about when we
say we a bad girl or a bad woman um i
also just want to talk about
if we could delineate what we mean a bit
by the by the bad boys thing because if
we mean the person that your mom doesn't
approve of well your mum may have
certain views that maybe do need
challenging and so her version of what a
bad boy is
may not be worthy of full consideration
um but if we mean and i think we need to
exclude from the bad boys category
people who uh beat up their girlfriends
can we just park that they're not just
they're not bad boys they're just
abusers um and so what we're left with
is basically the conversation around
narcissists deeply selfish men men for
who for whom a very long time the system
has allowed them to remain within the
boy category not having to take full
account for their responsibilities
being able to be deeply selfish in their
behavior and basically being um
midwived into adulthood in all
in a form in a shape
that looks like a man but is a is
basically a man-child
with all of the characteristics of a
child when it comes to accountability
selfishness etc um so yeah sorry i could
could go on but yes
we i think we infantilize uh men and
facilitate their behavior when we refer
to them as as boys you're you're a big
man you're just behaving like a child
okay thank you very much
so rowan is danger integral to desire
danger itself i mean no clearly not now
i do love esther perel but
you know i have a friend who said one
night you know i had a funny dream about
andrew marr we all know about weird
crutches my very first job
my first job i was working for ian
hislop the amount of love letters he got
every week now ian i would say who's a
wonderful man and great boss was the
very opposite of what we associate with
a bad boy but he had something i'd say
several qualities that are powerfully
attractive i think he has moral courage
and i think a lot of people find that
very attractive but of course if we're
going to i think what esther pearl's
really saying is something that we do
find
very integral to czar is slight hint of
unavailability of something we have to
work for of something that maybe we're
slightly frustrated by for a short while
because we don't understand so therefore
any celebrity can be the focus
of desire but i don't think danger
itself
uh has to be integral to desire having
said that
of course we do have this kind of
strong cultural thread which promotes
bad boys and i still blame the romantic
poets actually blame lovely lady
caroline lamb who famously said about
lord byron that he was mad bad and
dangerous to know and that kind of sunk
in and you know that's what mick
jagger's channeling that's what bloody
hell russell brand who's channeling you
know it is quite a strong thing and
i've barely ever talked to um a poet or
a kind of rock musician who hasn't said
on one level or another if he's a man
that the reason or comedians actually
the reason that
partially they went into it was to get
laid and so
you know you do have um a correlation
there and you know women have bought
into this i blame the brontes too
you know heathcliff
is literally you know when you first
read it you think oh god heathcliff's so
sexy because when you're young you're
kind of you know peer pressure makes you
get on certain channels of what you
think sort of approved sexuality is and
people like heathcliff look attractive
until you've worked out he's kind of a
wife beater he's a narcissist he's the
psychopath we're talking about he's
awful and then that eventually gets
channeled
into 50 shades of grey you know
christian grey i
really offended me in every single way
he's basically a stalker and you know a
psychopath and this was turned into
romantic fantasy for a lot of people so
you know there is there is a sort of
element of that but i would say we're
all morally complex if we evolve
properly men and women we start looking
for another morally complex human being
because you know if you just if you're
just looking for someone who is just
virtuous
you know how are you going to deal with
that you know i'm a bit of a shitty
human being i find it easier to deal
with someone who has the same level of
moral complexity
thank you very much
so we've already touched upon desire but
that brings us to our first theme to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas
you